POPULOUS STATE OF IN THE
COUNTRY, UNVEILING ITS PLAN FOR
NEXT PHASE OF THE PANDEMIC.
>> WHAT WE'RE ANNOUNCING HERE
TODAY IS ABOUT TURNING A PAGE.
MOVING FROM THIS CRISIS
MENTALITY, MOVING FROM A
REACTIVE FRAMEWORK, TO A
FRAMEWORK WHERE WE ARE MORE SET
IN OUR APPROACH, THAT WE STAND
FIRM AND CONFIDENT AS WE LEAN
INTO THE FUTURE, MOVING AWAY
FROM A REACTIVE MINDSET AND
CRISIS MINDSET, TO LIVING WITH
THIS VIRUS.
>> AND JOINING US NOW IS D
DR. OLLIE KHAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, DOCTOR, FOR
BEING WITH US.
FIRST, LET'S TALK ABOUT MASKING
AND WHERE AND WHEN YOU THINK IT
IS SAFE FOR ADULTS AND CHILDREN
TO BEGIN DROPPING MASKS INSIDE.
>> GOOD MORNING, BRIANNA.
SO IF YOU'RE FULLY BOOSTED, THAT
MEANS YOU'VE COMPLETED A
THREE-DOSE SERIES, THEN YOU CAN
BE COMFORTABLE DROPPING YOUR
MASK BASED ON YOUR PERSONAL RISK
LEVEL, HOW MUCH RISK YOU'RE
WILLING TO TAKE AND WHAT THE
RISK IN THE COMMUNITY LOOKS
LIKE.
I PERSONALLY WILL PROBABLY WAIT
UNTIL CASES GET DOWN TO MODERATE
LEVELS WITHIN MY COMMUNITY.
RIGHT NOW ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES I THINK EXCEPT FOR
MARYLAND EVERYBODY IS HIGH.
I WOULD WAIT A LITTLE BIT BEFORE
I RELEASED MY OWN MASK.
I'M TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE THAT
ARE FULLY BOOSTED.
THE RELEASE OF ALL THESE MASK
MANDATES IS GOING TO BE MOST
PROBLEMATIC FOR THOSE THAT ARE
UNVACCINATED OR UNDERVACCINATED.
THEY WILL LIKELY HAVE A REBOUND
OF DISEASE WITHIN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
>> DR. KHAN, FIRST OF ALL,
YOU'VE BEEN ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
PEOPLE TO TALK TO OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS, FIRST, THE COMIC
BOOKS BEHIND YOU WHICH I LOVE,
BUT AT THE END OF EVERY SEGMENT,
YOU TELL US TO MASK ON AND PUT
YOUR MASK ON.
ONE OF THE REASONS WE'RE EXCITED
TO TALK TO YOU TODAY IS TO
FIGURE OUT AS YOU STARTED
TALKING ABOUT IT RIGHT THERE,
WHEN TO TAKE THE MASKS OFF AS
MANY STATES AND CITIES ARE NOW
DOING, BUT YOU SAY WHEN WE HAVE
THESE ELEVATED LEVELS OF
TRANSMISSION, WHICH IS
EVERYWHERE, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
MAP, IT IS ALL STILL RED, IT
SOUNDS LIKE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS EVEN IF YOU'RE BOOSTED, THE
LEVELS ARE TOO HIGH FOR YOU TO
BE COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
>> IT DEPEND S ON WHAT YOUR
PERSONAL RISK LEVEL IS.
SO I'M OUT AND ABOUT IN MY
COMMUNITY ALL THE TIME, I TRAVEL
ALL THE TIME, HOWEVER WHEN I'M
IN A CROWDED INDOOR SPACE, WITH
PEOPLE WHERE I DON'T KNOW THEIR
VACCINATION STATUS, I'M STILL
WEARING A MASK BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO GET INFECTED AT ALL
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GET LONG
COVID, I DON'T WANT TO GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH COMPLICATIONS WE
SEE IN PEOPLE WHO GET COVID
INFECTIONS, I WOULD RATHER STAY
AWAY FROM THAT.
OTHER PEOPLE MAY NOT WORRY
ABOUT MILD ILLNESS AND SAY,
OKAY, I'M WILLING TO GO OUT AND
ABOUT.
BUT, AGAIN, BOOSTED, BUT THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE UNVACCINATED OR
UNDERVACCINATED STILL, THIS IS
NOT A DISEASE YOU WANT.
IT IS A SEVERE DISEASE AND WE
HAVE 2,000 DEATHS A DAY.
THAT WOULD MAKE COVID VACCINE
PREVENTABLE DISEASED LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IN AMERICA IF WE
STAY AT 2,000 TO 2500 DEATHS A
DAY RIGHT NOW.
>> WHEN YOU SAY MODERATE LEVELS,
BECAUSE THAT'S THE TIPPING POINT
I THINK IF YOU'RE CONSIDERING
TAKING OFF YOUR MASK IN A SMART
WAY, IF YOU'RE BOOSTED, WHAT IS
THAT?
WHAT IS THE MODERATE LEVEL FOR
100,000 PEOPLE?
>> SO, CDC PUTS THAT AT ABOUT
SEVEN CASES PER 100,000 PEOPLE,
49 CASES PER WEEK, SO YOU CAN
LOOK ON THE CDC WEBSITE.
SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE, 5 TO 10,
IS WHERE PEOPLE WOULD FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
RIGHT NOW NATIONALLY I THINK,
BRIANNA, WE'RE AT 35 CASES PER
100,000.
SO ABOUT A THIRD OF THAT I THINK
WOULD BE PRETTY GOOD FOR
MODERATE.
SO WE GO FROM HIGH TO
SUBSTANTIAL TO MODERATE.
>> SO LET ME -- I WANT TO ASK
YOU A QUESTION, THIS IS
SOMETHING I CAME ACROSS IN MY
FAMILY, I HAVE A RELATIVE WHO
SAY TEACHER IN CALIFORNIA, AND
EVEN AHEAD OF THIS CALIFORNIA
RECOMMENDATION THEY'RE MAKING
MASKS OPTIONAL IN SCHOOLS.
WHICH I THINK IS SOMETHING IN
THIS AREA THAT A LOT OF PARENTS
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF, AND I WAS LOOKING AT THE
CASE COUNT FOR THIS COUNTY, AND
IT IS BASED ON THE SEVEN-DAY
AVERAGE, 134 CASES PER 100,000
OR 106 CASES BASED ON
YESTERDAY'S COUNT PER 100,000.
THAT'S, LIKE, HUGE, COMPARED TO
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AS
MODERATE.
>> CORRECT.
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND PARENTS
THAT SCHOOLS DON'T NEED TO
BECOME IDEOLOGICAL BATTLEFIELDS.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN KID, BY GETTING THAT
CHILD VACCINATED, THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THAT CHILD WEAR
A HIGH QUALITY MASK, TO PROTECT
THEM, THIS IS NOT, YOU KNOW,
JANUARY OF 2021, WE HAVE
VACCINES AVAILABLE FOR KIDS, WE
HAVE FREE MASKS, SO WE HAVE
OPTIONS FOR PARENTS THAT WERE
NOT AVAILABLE LAST -- WHEN THEY
WERE WORRIED ABOUT SENDING THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL.
>> CAN I READ THE THOUGHT BUBBLE
THAT WENT UP OVER BRIANNA
KEILAR'S HEAD THERE, YOU SAID WE
HAVE VACCINES FOR KIDS, THE
THOUGHT BUBBLE THAT WENT UP WAS,
YEAH, BUT NOT FOR KIDS UNDER 5.
NOT FOR KIDS UNDER 5.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> I LOVE THAT AGE FOR KIDS
UNDER 5.
SO I THINK THE DATA IS PRETTY
GOOD ON -- FOR KIDS UNDER 5, IF
YOU SURROUND THEM WITH PEOPLE
WHO ARE VACCINATED, BRIANNA,
THEY'RE -- THE KIDS DON'T GET
INFECTED.
THERE IS A NICE REPORT OUT TWO
WEEKS AGO FROM CDC, SO THE
PARENTS, GRANDPARENTS, TEACHERS
ARE VACCINATED AROUND THEM, THE
KID DOES JUST FINE.
SO THERE IS WAYS TO PROTECT
THOSE FOR WHOM VACCINES ARE NOT
AVAILABLE AT THIS POINT.
THAT SMALL GROUP OF KIDS UNDER
5.
>> MY CHILD IN PARTICULAR IS
AROUND OTHER UNVACCINATED KIDS
UNDER 5, BUT THAT'S ALSO -- YOU
MAKE THE RISK ASSESSMENT AND FOR
US THE SCHOOLING IS SO
IMPORTANT.
>> BECAUSE THE ISSUE THEN
BECOMES, DR. KHAN, THE -- TOWNS
AND STATES ARE MAKING THIS
DECISION BASED ON THE RISKS THAT
THEY WANT THEIR LOCALITIES AND
PARENTS ARE MAKING THE DECISIONS
BASED ON RISKS.
THE CDC STILL SAYS NO.
AT WHAT POINT, IF THE CDC IS
TELLING PEOPLE SOMETHING THAT
THEY KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
IGNORING, WHAT IS THE POINT?
>> WELL, JOHN, THE CDC IS
TELLING EVERYBODY TO GO OUT
THERE AND GET BOOSTED AND THE
NATIONAL BOOST RATE IS 28%.
SO IT IS THE SAME EXACT
ARGUMENT, RIGHT?
IF PEOPLE GOT BOOSTED, WE WOULD
BE IN IT A DIFFERENT PLACE.
WE KNOW THAT OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT ARE RELEASING THEIR MASK
RECOMMENDATIONS AND OTHER SOCIAL
DISTANCING RECOMMENDATIONS IN
EUROPE, THEY'RE ABLE TO DO IT
BECAUSE THEIR RATES OF
VACCINATION ARE SO MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE UNITED STATES, WHICH
GOES BACK TO WHERE WE STARTED
WITH CALIFORNIA, VERY
APPROPRIATE FOR CALIFORNIA TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
THE VACCINATION RATE IS HIGHER
THAN THE REST OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY'RE ABOUT TO VACCINATE KIDS,
I BELIEVE, THIS FALL, WHICH ILL
INCREASE THE VACCINATION RATE
EVEN MORE.
SO YOU HAVE LOTS OF LATITUDE TO
DROP MASKS, DROP SOCIAL
DISTANCING IF YOU'RE WILLING TO
GET VACCINATED.
>> DR. KHAN, IT IS SO GREAT TO
TALK TO YOU.
I THINK YOU ALWAYS HELP US KIND
OF BALANCE ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS, BECAUSE THAT'S
REALLY WHAT IT IS.
IT IS ABOUT BALANCING
PRIORITIES, AND SAFETY AND RISK
AND YOU MADE A LOT OF SENSE.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU, ALWAYS A PLEASURE.
YOU KNOW MY MESSAGE, YOU KNOW
WHAT IT IS GOING TO BE, GET
BOOSTED!
>> GET BOOST